how the gun rest my name feel bad
welcome back to some more afraid the
monsters if I can jump the box
alright the reason why I haven't been
recording this because I've been stuck
at that part that part was a living hell
ah this is much more the lighting all
right Forrest show me what you got for
me
I'm not afraid I lovely water without a
lake without water isn't that you
blending oh I see you from that BAM
that's what your mama said when she
spanked you okay all right they're all
dead oh they're not all dead BAM and
your face all right we're good fantastic
ah [ __ ] just give me a break
don't bring me all snappish newb they he
just wanted to hug my face I get it I
have a lovely face but that doesn't mean
you have to harass me you're going down
to thank you very much all right um
lovely house lovely Oh what do you want
from me what do you want from me talk
like a normal person I would smash nice
you you see that oh he died I was gonna
smash the wall I'm so sorry
at least his dream came true he always
wanted to lick his own toes I'm a dream
for failure of all sides hey I got some
more batteries and drugs yes I needed
those drugs
thank you thank you bathroom that's it
looks awful but anyway hey blood on the
wall okay
I'm alright I don't even know anymore oh
no man what did I tell you oh you nearly
kill me Robin
well done you're a fighter alright it's
really persistent you're killing me it's
after I raped his mother it's fully
understandable
alright let's see what this is going we
have more ammo and stuff where where
where is a little [ __ ] oh [ __ ] me my
mom ha ha ha ha
alright we're good but we're not good
we're not [ __ ] good boom gotta get
down boom boom gotta get that alright
having a thingy I don't know what I did
I lighten up a path lovely love oh come
on stop makes your sense it you come
from there stop it alright let's go here
it's closed
alright fine so what do I do exactly oh
holy [ __ ]
calm down calm down you [ __ ] Charter
holy [ __ ]
alright there we go the gate has
happened the thing is I I don't think
this is gonna work
back out alright
it should be over here alright let's see
alright holy [ __ ] alright pretty cool
I'm in a subway station thingy sub sewer
sewer that's why they called back in the
sewers
anyone in here I don't want to go down
there
hello ah ha ha ha progressing lack of
bass
alright luckily someone pulled down
their penis for me thank you very much
oh snap oh I like this no sir I don't
like you know you all know biggest and
watch one side hello tree stop making
these noises alright so we need to open
the gate again but how the mysteries of
life what is that noise someone lets
some drugs by the door thank you thank
you very much lovely house I love what
you've done with the place
just absolutely 0:16 I don't know what
that sound was
but let's go down here helau and boom
boom gotta get that boom boom boom
alright had yes
alright the gate should be open all
right all right what did I tell you
about going on without the shot you will
be called I'm just worried about your
health that's it I don't want anything
else oh oh
snappy snoo oh do you think you're just
gonna creep up on me no snappy soon look
at this I have an axe yes yes yes
this is tremendous oh wow I grind that
[ __ ]
wow it sounds some loud I get shivers
and it's like when people do their nails
on though
thingy out all right I have an axe if
anyone wants to fight with me you fight
with the axe this big action is ah here
you go
don't speak action into my face I'll
teach you but be careful
it hurts it has at heart
Oh No nice nippleless gotta give him
props for the nipples all right fine
back why do you never [ __ ] die holy
[ __ ]
about the van hope you're [ __ ] proud
of yourself grind that [ __ ] oh no that's
a problem all right
hey are you doing how's everyone feeling
how's that established nervous episodes
episodes episode what do i do what do i
do what it would do what do i do what
else speaks back smash me on ax knee
make it speak my language all right so
far I don't even know anymore
oh [ __ ] speak my language spigot hey oh
no I'm pretty good there I need a battle
plan speak my language eat it oh snap
tap tap tap tap time time time time time
time
oh [ __ ] they're two of them it's our
three of them polish [ __ ] this is epic
smash nice smash knees smashing is that
was freaking triple kill all right uh-oh
hey Dex it all of it ha ha ha ha ha you
don't mess with Peter pie with an axe
this is written in stone alright where
do we go sort of trailing the forest
open where do I go oh it's the trail
over here lovely why this is nice
oh [ __ ] me dogs don't rejected ah done
okay they explode SuperDuper ah [ __ ]
everywhere just give me a [ __ ] break
ah I hate those little [ __ ] not gonna
lie
alright let's keep going I'm more dogs
all right we're good
I'm saving like a bar share but it is
tunnel
I love tunnels now it's been a big fan
of tunnels I like Thomas on Facebook
even way way
oh stop spam right in your face right on
your left nipple right on your right
nipple holy [ __ ] that was awesome
alright okay hey drugs
lovely let's go down here where am i oh
no I don't like this hello
oh nice we purchased again lovely just
lovely ram i hello what did i go back
it's an empty room
let me oh why did I come from here I
came from a hmm
shotgun thank you Jesus Oh more stuff
they are quite generous
okay so we should progress over here oh
no oh no no no oh no metal guys
everywhere oh snap it's no sabes Dipper
guys everywhere nipple gash everywhere
nipple guys ever oh my gosh oh my did
you forget someone any because I don't
even know anymore okay okay I get it I
get it you're jealous
you're jealous but don't fight me we are
all friends here
polish I don't even know anymore Ellen
DeGeneres please save me
anyone would be gone back I need you
where is she where's your [ __ ] leader
ah at cetera never guy but I love your
nipple guys all of you one by one you
apart by the nipple master I am the
level master all right
it's no use it's no [ __ ] out leave me
alone Ellen DeGeneres is gonna come here
any second
she's gonna be pissed she's gonna be
really pissed
Marcus than I am right now of your
performance holy [ __ ] there's many of
you bamm-bamm right in your nipple all
right bum ba-bum ba-bum all right brush
it this chill out oh never mind
wrong gone right which one gone is it oh
no oh that scared me
wait [ __ ] God is it all right is it
this one no it's not that one it's this
one no I don't [ __ ] me all right
I am the nipple master I hope you will
learn from this lesson
all right here we go silly nipple people
they never learn like it's so many times
I just try to explain to them that I
have Whoopi Goldberg and Ellen DeGeneres
on my side and I don't appreciate what
they're doing so they're just gonna end
up in the trash along with other people
that are not very emotional lovely
lovely lovely lovely
I [ __ ] rape those people you saw that
[ __ ] that was MLG
I should start my
client it's going to be called degeneres
destroyers and Whoopi Goldberg is cool
too oh no it's the fangirls [ __ ] me I
hate the fangirls alright I'm sorry but
I can't talk right now I off [ __ ] oh oh
I get it I get it I get it
you want hugs but no not today no sir
alright I kill while you live that when
would you learn ah they will never learn
let's just go here alright what is this
a house I hate house their haunted I
don't appreciate it Oh fine but the job
let me oh I want to set a real bad word
I'm sorry
how you doing mean to do it Oh nope nope
sir nobody snow I'm gonna any hair bros
like a favorite Asian George you've
gotta come a bro today and I'm and I'm
[Music]
hey homie man oh I don't chop you're
working together
come on kitty oh whoa oh no